abone ol
e herkese merhaba ben hala ben çıktım ve
şimdi bu kelimeyi Ben ilk defa yüksek
sesli söylüyorum benim için bir ilk oldu
bu konuşma 10 yıldır Türk işi mezun oldu
ile ya da bu hesaptan paylaşımlar
yapmaya da bazı yazılarda Adam'ın
yanında böyle hali minimalist ya da hala
canım yazmasına rağmen bunu hiç kendim
için kullanmadığımı fark ettim çünkü bu
bir etik etti ve ben bu etki üzerime
aldığımda siz bana baktığımda ki bugün
kıyafetin bir minimalizm şeyle çok
uyumlu Ben Bunun gerisini düşüneceksiniz
evi nasıl duvarlarında tablo var mı Kaç
kitabı var hiç kitap tutuyormu evde Kaç
kişiler doğal mutfak dolaplarında evdeki
kişi sayısı kadar mı acaba çatal bıçak
var aslında ben bu algıların bu
yapıştırmalar ın dışına çıkmak amacıyla
O benim Ezine ilk tanıştığımda dedim ki
bunu çok kişi yapalım O yüzden hadi bir
on yıl geriye gidelim istiyorum ben daha
yeni mezun olmuş kendine yeni bir
pazarlama uzman yardımcısı olarak işe
başlamışken düşük bir maaşla geliş maaşı
da işe başladım Benim için sorun yoktu
çünkü zaten ailemle yaşadım Annem de
Yaşıyordum para kiranız yoktu bir
şeyimiz yoktu evden henüz benim bir
birey olduğumda Zaten onlar tarafından O
kadar Kabul edilmediği için katkı
beklentileri de yoktu bana kalıyor
istediğim gibi yapımı içiyordum Ama
yemek içmek soyut kalıyordu Yani ortada
bir şey göremiyordum ve benim kazandığım
parayı bir şekilde kendimiz patlamam
gerekiyordu Ne de olsa ben artık
üniversite mezunu işe girmiş bir genç
kadındım bunu nasıl göstermedim diye
düşündüm ve kendime en kolay olarak
alışverişi Block ucuzlukları takip etmek
o zamanlar şu anda on yıl
Evet şimdi unutmayalım dünya Trendyol
Dünyası değil dünya galiba Markafoni
Dünyası bir tanesi de var gidiyorsunuz
her gün belli başlı 35 markanın işte
20-30 ürünü sınırlı sayıda şey sunuluyor
satışa sunuluyor bunlar arasında her gün
bakarak alışveriş yapabiliyorsunuz
online Ticaret biraz daha buralarda işte
GittiGidiyor gibi ikinci el siteleri var
Bir de şu anki markalardan Mango ilk
defa online sipariş açıldı Şimdi herkes
iş yerinde farklı mollalara Çıkarken ben
onlarda gidiyor gidiyorum oturuyorum
bilgisayarın başına işte ilk site Outlet
sırala ucuzdan pahalıya sırala bakim de
varmış Bu aileler alabilirim kendime iki
haftada bir falan şirketi sürekli
poşetler kargolar geliyor Ben çok
mutluyum dolabındaki kıyafetleri artıyor
bakıyorum maddi olarak zengin Yani
ortada bir şeyler var Çünkü zaten gerisi
ile ilgilen
Bu annemin alanı Benim adamım Kendi odam
bakıyorum duvarlarda işte çeşitli
seyahatlerden aldığım ufak tefek ıvır
bir sürü şey milyonlarca fotoğraf ve
artık böyle askılar ve omuzları neymiş
üzerlerinde 34 gömlek ya da işte Belleri
bükülmüş üzerinde 4-5 tane et 4-5 tane
pantolon atmakta A ben çok yüklüyorum
bakıyorum Okey Ben iyiyim ya para
kazanıyorum Bu da ispatı Çünkü o zaman
bunun böyle bir ispatı olduğuna
inanıyordu sonra ve bir on yıl geride
bir Instagram'da evde değil de bir blog
devre bloglar arasında gezinirken bir
kelimeyle karşılaştık 1'er 1'er şimdi
İngilizce bir bölümden mezun oldum
Boğaziçi uluslarası ilişkiler mezunuyum
İngilizcem var ama dikkat kelimesini
bilmiyorum ve gelmemiştim Yani bu ses
politikada geçmeyen bir kelime olmuş o
zamana kadar arama photo
11 12 o kelimeyi bilmesem de ne
anlattığını Anlıyorum bir kadın var bir
derdi var öncesi sonrası fotoğraflarını
koymuş öncesi fotoğraflar Kıyafet eşya
üst üste her şey kalabalık dağınık ve
bunaltıcı bir anlamda sonrası
fotoğrafları var iç açıcı huzur veren
eşyası değil ama bir düzene olan Ama bu
sadece derleyip toplamak hani böyle
derle topla onunla ilgili değil yani
sadece bir işte dolaba kıyafetleri
düzenli koyduk değil de bir
ya gerçekten yeter eşya ile yaşamanın
ferahlığı var ortada kişisel olarak
gerçek hikayelerden çok etkileniyorum
bana çok ilham veriyorlar bunun üzerine
okumaya başladım anladım ki bir kılıftır
Katılıyor ortada yok etmek zaten değil
negatiflik getiriyor Ha demek ki bu
insanlar bir dağınıklık toparlama
peşinde ama nasıl koparıyorlar bunu
Oradan da geldik Daha büyük Konsept olan
minimalizme bundan o yalancı ile
karşılaştı ilk okuduğum insanlar
Yurtdışından Amerika'dan şıdı minimalist
trivago şu an ve o bota Fransızca gibi
yazarlardı O zamanlar daha kitapları
yoktu hepsi birer blok yazarıydı düzenli
olarak içerik paylaşıyor onlar da kendi
o zaman ki serüvenlerini aktarıyorlar
the bunu çok etkilendim ve böyle
Gerçekten bu sabah da bunu söyledim
böyle gidip İşyerindeki herkesi şöyle
bir sarılmak istedim Ya baksana böyle
birşey vardı
Bu arada insanlar farklı bir şey doğru
yürüyor o zamana kadar Bu arada bütün
alışverişi manisinin alışverişe bir
İroni olarak bir yandan da çok rahatsız
oluyordu çalışıyorum Benim bir kalemim
var benim defterim var bir tane işte
laptopun var ama bazı insanlar masasında
30 tane tükenmez kalemler var ya sen Bir
senede bir tane tükenmez kendimi zor
bitirirken 30 tane aynı renk Tükenmez
kalemin ihtiyacım var ya da biz annemle
yaşıyoruz elimizde 30 tane çay bardağı
var ya biz iki kişiyiz bize Kaç Misafir
gelebilir neden Belki bir gün çok kişi
gelirse diye bu kadar çok eşyayı ya
lazım olursa diye saklamak zorunda
yazıyor Bir yandan bunun içinde
sıkıntısını yaşıyorum ama benim de bir
uyanma çağrısını ihtiyacım vardır bilmez
ile çalışmak Bana da tam bu çağrıyı
yaptı
Az önce okuduklarımı eve gidip kendi
gardrobundan başlayarak uygulamaya
başladı
O biraz utanç verici Çünkü dolabı
açtığımda biliyordum giymediğim bazı
şeyler oldu Çünkü tam bir Klişe olarak
dolap dolu ve her sabah yarın ne gibi
her sabah bugün işe ne giyeceğim diye
uyanıyorum Böyle bir saçmalık var çünkü
alıyorum ama ucuz olduğu için alıyorum
kampanyada olduğu için alıyorum Alıyorum
zayıflarım diye oluyorum bu renge bir
şey bulurum diye alıyorum dolabında ne
var bilmiyorum ve bu kadar şeyi alıp
yine aynı şeyleri gidip devam ediyorum
da o zaman kapsül Gardırop falan
bilmiyorum da
Bu doğru mu açıp da üzerindeki
etiketiyle Duran kıyafetler ya da ne
bileyim hiç altı aydır bir senedir İki
senedir bilmediğim kıyafetlerle
yüzleşince bunları elemeye başladım ben
atmak kelimesinin hoşlanmıyorum elemek
ve daha sonra doğru yerlere ulaştırmak
peşindeyim bunu yaptıkça ve okudukça
tabi İnsan merak ediyor arama motoruna
yazıyorum minimalizm diye Türkçe söyle o
bana diyor ki minimalizm ne demek
istediniz diyor hayır minimalizm demek
istedim diyorum yok böyle bir içerik yok
Bak o zaman dedim Ben yazmayı seviyorum
Orada bir şey var ben çok etkilendim
şirketteki en geniş insanlardan bir kötü
biriyim kimseye gidip sırtından
Omuzlarından sarsma şansım yok o zaman
ben dedim hissettiklerimi anlatayım
öğrendiklerimi kaynaklarıyla beraber
aktarayım ki benim gibi başka insanlarda
Bunlar ilham alsınlar Tabi bir şey
Ben bir şey yapmaya çalışırken Bence
hedefimiz en ucuza en böyle uçak örneğe
gitmek olmasada hepimiz kendi Elimizden
geldiği kadar bunu yapsak da da en iyi
örnekleri görmek gerekiyor bence bu
örneklere Baktım bununla var sadece 100
eşyayla hayatını sürdürüyordu yüz Herşey
Dahil sonra Matilda kahve vardı işi
sadece beyaz gömlek ve siyah pantolonunu
giy gidiyordu Şu Çünkü bir gün çok
önemli bu di reklam ajansında çalışan
kreatif direktör bir gün bir toplantıya
çok önemli toplantı içi olduğu için Ne
giyeceğini düşünmekten geç kalıyor ve bu
onlara bir ders oluyor ki diyor ki Okey
ben bundan sonra sadece beyaz gömlek
siyah pantolon çeşit olacağım ve ne
giyeceğim gideceğim ben yaratıcı bir
insanım şirketimin Benim yaratıcı
fikirlerin ihtiyacı var daldık değerli
vakti mi acaba ne giysem diye düşünerek
harç
Bu bir başka çift daha vardı Onların
isimlerini yazıp hatırlayamıyorum yoktan
bir çift sadece 16 metrekarelik bir evde
yaşıyorlar evleri şurada yatakla
başlıyor bir müzik sesleri mutfakta
bitiyor Bir tane arada banyoları var
kıyafetlerini mutfak dolaplarında
saklıyorlar tabi iyice uç bir çift işte
kıyafetlerin yarısı işyerinde evde
çamaşır çıkamıyorlar Kuru temizlemeye
götürüyorlar vesaire ama 16 metrekarelik
bir alanda Niye ok gibi koca bir şehrin
ortasında kedileriyle yaşayabiliyorlar
yani mümkün Konfor alanımızın dışına
çıktığımızda orada bir hayatın olduğunu
görebildiğimiz örnekler buna ben de
oturdum bu örneklerde öğrendim başka
şeyleri Türkiye Şimdi mezun ama altında
yazmaya ve paylaşmaya başladı bu kadar
minimalizmin dedik O zaman bir de
anlamını tanımını konuşalım istedim
genelde bunu yazdığın zaman karşınıza
çıkan şeyle siz mi
bu yaz çoktur az çok turda az nedir Ne
çoktur niye çoktur
Ben okuduğum Bunca şeyden sonra ben
kendimi şöyle bir tanım çıkardım
evet Hadi herkes şunu da hemfikir
eşyalar ya sizi bir amaç için hizmet
etmeli ya da sizi gerçekten mutlu etmeli
o zaman dedim Bence minimalizm sizi
mutlu eden Az ve öz eşyayla bu huzurlu
bir yaşam sürmek bu somut anlamı cepte
yani eşyalar için daha var ki bence çok
değerli soyut anlamı O da size dayatılan
hedefler markalar yaşantılar bunlarla
soluklanıp gerçekten içerde Ne
istediğinizi odaklanmak Bence bu kısmı
Evet eşya halledilir Ama bu ikinci kısmı
eşyadan sonra gelinmesi gereken ve bence
insanın hayatını değiştiren kısmını
Özgürlüğe Giden yolda Asıl sizi
özgürleştiren kısmı Belki de burası ne
kastediyoruz bundan Siz o dönemin
popüler işi işte robotlar sa herkes bunu
da para olduğunu düşünüyorsan üniversite
tercih
Bu sadece puanımız ile bu tutuyor diye
Bu bölüme gitmek değil de sizin
içinizdeki Aslı 8 meslek neyse onu uygun
bölümü seçmek ya da sanat dalının spor
Dalını seçmek giyinirken sizin
sevdiğiniz size yakıştığını inandığınız
içinde mutlu olduğumuz şeyleri giymek
yerine başkalarının size de yaptığı şu
marka giymelisin Trend olmak istiyorsan
buradan giymelisin laflarını kafa
çevirmek Hayır ben kendim olmak
istediğim gibi olmak istiyorum Sizin dua
et iyi çalışan bir telefonumuz varken ve
ondan mutluyken sırf yenisi çıktı diye
sırf herkes bunu alıyor diye insanların
yanında kendinizi iyi hissetmek için o
telefonu İhtiyacınız olduğunu bilmemek
ihtiyacınız olmadığını bilmek kısmı bu
ve Bence insanlar böyle zincirlerinden
ayıran koparan ve insanı gerçekten
özgürleştiren gittiği yılda yetmesi
ilerleyebilmesi için onu motive eden
kısmında bu gidelim sonuç
bu somut kısmına çok değerli şimdi
eşyalar diyoruz eşyaları azaltmak Tan
bahsediyoruz bu eşyalar evinizde
gerçekten Aslında çok ciddi bir yer
kaplıyorlar Sizin gözünüz o kadar
oluşuyor ki ben şimdi bardağı Şuraya
koydum bu Bayraklı'da bir hafta kalsa
bir hafta daha kalsın Sonra bardağı
oranın süs olarak algılayacak Gözünüz
kendi evinizi düşünün böyle sehpaya
bırakılan bir anahtarlık belki gelen bir
zarf Durdukça muz elinde başka şeyler
geldikçe Biz alanları doldurmaya Çünkü
içgüdüsel olarak meyilliyiz kalabalık
yaratıyoruz ve bunu çok benimsiyoruz
Bunun farkına varamıyoruz bu
kalabalıktan uzaklaştığımız da doğru
sorularla bunlar niye burada ben ya buna
sahibim Ben bunu kullanıyor muyum bunu
yeri burasımı gibi sorgulayıcı soruları
sorup da bu fazla eşyadan kurtulduğumuz
zaman alan kazanıyorsunuz Ben şu anda
size Siz daha çok bireysel yaşamları
yaşıyor
bu yaş itibariyle ufacık bir oda yeterli
oluyor olabilir ama yaş ilerledikçe
kendinize ait bir alanın ne kadar
değerli olduğunu Bu alanın metrekareleri
ne kadar pahalı olduğunu öğreneceksiniz
tecrübeyle Bu birincisi ikincisi eşyalar
Emek İster ayakkabılar boyanmak ister
kıyafetler havalandırmak ister nevresim
takımları havlular düzenlenme kötülenmek
toparlanmak ister yerler süpürmek işte
taraflardaki eşyalar toz alınmak ister
bazı eşyalar yağlanıp bazı eşyalar başka
bakımlar ister Yani eşya dediğin
sorumluluktur kenara atıp da Eğer onu
çürümeye bırakmıyor Sam onu
sorumluluğunu almalısın Eğer sen
Gerçekten ihtiyacın olan şeyleri ben de
sadece Onlarla ilgileniyorsa bu da sana
zaman kazandırır
bu alışverişte Geçen Zamanı Say gördü O
da cepte son olarak Gerçekten ihtiyacın
olan şeyleri aldığında alışverişine bir
disiplin Getirdiğimde belki Tabiri
caizse o zaman paramda cebimde kalır
Oğlum para ve zaman bunların içinde çok
değerli şeyler ve ben diyorum ki kendi
deneyiminden de yola çıkarak minimalizm
sızı zaman para ve alan kazandırır ya bu
size özgürleştirir Hatta daha ileri
gidiyorum sizi istediğiniz şey yapmak
konusunda cesaretlendirir ve
zenginleştirir İşte benim hikayem de
aslında bununla beraber gelişti Tamam
artık eşyalar konusunda bilinçli idim
kafamda da toplumun Bana da
yaptıklarından değil de kendi gitmek
istediğim yolda gitme konusundada
kararlıydım Ama bu denklem bir şey Siz
eksik kalıyordu O da alışveriş disipline
alışveriş alışkanlıklarını değiştirmek
daha doğrusu
ve eğer aşağıya çalışkanlığı
değiştirmezseniz Sizin yaptığınız sadece
bir bahar temizliği gibi oluyor Tamam
sen evi temizliyorsun Sonra gidip aynı
eşyaları böyle poşet poşet torba torba
Kargo kargo koli koli yeni aldığınız
zaman bunun bir anlamı kalmıyor ve bunu
asıl dikkate almak ve burada değişim
yapmak bana doğudan ne kadar koktuğunu
fark ettirdi eşyaları sadece eşya olarak
bakarken daha ilerisini görmeye başladım
bir kere bir şey olurken ihtiyacım var
mı falan bunları sorduk sonra şu sormaya
başladım bu paraya değer mi bunu buradan
mı almalıyım bu iyi üretilmiş mi
kalitesi iyimi Hatta daha ileri
gidiyorum mekik şartlarda üretilmiş
Acaba bunu üretirken ne kadar enerji
harcanıyor bu hassasiyete de varınca da
zaten yolum dünyada artan 06 trendi ile
kesişti
bu fark ettim ki kendimce çevreye
duyarlı bir insandım olduğum için çok
fazla çaba harcamıyorum elimde çok
derdimi ayırmanın yeterli olduğunu
düşünüyordu ama iş yerine gidip ve
plastik şişe doğrusu varsa bunu
rahatlıkla içiyordum ya da dışarıda
içtiğim şey bir karton bardakta mı başka
bir bardaktan bunları falan sorgulamıyor
du yavaş yavaş sıfıratık af itibariyle
adına sıfır olduğu için insan çok itham
bir kavram olabiliyor hangi ki Belki
kilo ve istediğimiz düşük atık az atık
bu şekilde yaklaşırsak biraz daha o
kelimeyi duymuş atmak mümkün lan de
dönüp Neler yapabileceğimi Bak internet
zaten bu konuda bilgi dolu bu konuda
benim ben de bu daha iyi olmak üzere
birçok insanın yazdığı ufak değişimler
küçük adımlar büyük adımlar hepsini
bulabilirsiniz bir şey suyun taşıyarak
başladı Bence herhangi bir insanım ya
en iyi en basit adım bu insanı suya
ihtiyacımız var su içiyoruz dışarıda o
zaman Mümkünse kendi suyunu taşıyım Eğer
mümkünse onu tekrar doldurayım Afiyet
olsun ve dışarıdaki insanlara da
yaptıklarını da bir örnek olayım Bu
güzeldi Bu da cepte hiçbir şey daha
benim çok canımı sıkıyor ta işyerinde
çalıştığım ofislerdeki o plazalardaki
hayattan biri Canını sıkan bir şey
insanlar hiç mekanlarda otururken ve
kahveden karton bardaklar da alıyorlar
bu çok rahatsız ediyordu beni Yani bir
kere tadı değişiyor O kahvenin güzel
araması gidiyor bir yandan da bir yerde
oturuyorsan Niye bir karton var da
ihtiyacım var hatta bir adım ileri
gidiyorum böyle kahve alıp bir yere
gideceksen de niye karton bardak
ihtiyacım var Eğer beni bir kahve
içeceğiz insan her gün kahve İçiyorsam O
zaman benim bunun sorumluluğunu alıp bir
termos bardak Metal
O zaman bu bardak bir alternatif bulup
hatta yurt dışına bu işi kavanozlarla
istek katetti çekmek için işte Messenger
denilen Kutlu kavanozlarla yapanlar çok
oldu amaç dikkat çekmekte neden dedim
bizde bunu yapmıyoruz ülkemizdeki en
yaygın kahve zinciri Bunu zaten gruba
yol Global olarak yapsa da üçüncü dalga
kahvenin yayılmasıyla beraber gerçekten
sayı binleri bulan kahve dükkanlarının
bu konuda pek de bir adımları olmadığını
gördüm sorunca w2018 yıl 2019'un ocak
ayında dedim ki o zaman Kafan termosta
diyelim şimdi sabah Umarım logoyu
görebilirsiniz bardağı göstermek
istiyorum
bu şöyle bir de logo yaptık dikkat
çeksin bunu markalaştı Imm insanların
aklında kalsın diye kavram Tanrısı benim
için çok değerli bir hareket oldu ilk
gün bunu anlattığımda dört tane Mekandan
olumlu sonuç aldık bir fotoğraf çektim
Ben bunu yaydım üstüne yazı yazdım
sevgili nokta nokta atıyorum sıfıratık
yolunda ve diyorum ki kafam termosta
kahvemi sarması almaya geliyorum sen de
bana doğru bir adım gel bu adamı gör
beni destekle Sen de bana indirim var bu
çarkı ne mutlu ki Instagram'dan başladı
Twitter'da linkedin'de asıl kahve
tüketen insanlar arasında büyük Yankı
buldu bazı şirketler çağrı merkezleri
şirketlerindeki karton bardaklar
bıraktılar bazı bireyler farkındalığını
alıp kendi ofislerinde bile olsa bu
hareketi veren istedi binlerce insan
gerçekten binlerce insan Artık
termosuyla dışarı çıkmaya başladı
ne zaman tatile evde yapmak zorunda
değil dışarıdan alırken de bunu
kullanmaya başladım ve Bir yılın sonunda
Türkiye'nin 22 elinde 180 tane mekan bu
çağrıya şu anda destek veriyor Bu da
galiba benim hayatımda işte pazarlama
alanında birçok proje yaptım Belki bir
sürü şey imza attım ama beni en mutlu
eden en işe yaradığını hissettiren proje
oldu benim bu noktaya Geçende Aslında
benim ezme oldu dediğim gibi Çünkü ben
ne yapmak istediğimi hangi Çağrı yapmak
istediğimi Hangi yolda özgürce yürümek
istediğimi mezun sayesinde karar verdim
Umarım sizde buradan çıktığınızda
Etrafınıza eve döndüğünüzde bir bakar
eşyalarınız da yüzleşir ve Konfor
alanından bir adım dışarı çıkmaya
cesaret edersin Çok teşekkür ederim O
abone ol